today we're doing a fake guru tear list
with spencer cornelia say hi spencer hi
but first i have to admit something to
you guys merry christmas by the way i
failed i know it seems dramatic yes it's
true though in quite literal sense i
have failed and i'm not talking about
the subscriber challenge trying to get
to a million in one month we're not that
close to be honest with you guys 130 000
still to go
listen mr beast could still come though
and save us but
i'm actually talking about the daily
uploads
yeah
i have failed i i didn't upload
yesterday and i'm not gonna upload
regularly i've still got a couple
uploads left but i just wanted to
address that real quick it's not because
i'm depressed it's not because anything
happened i have failed honestly because
i ran out of ideas that's
that's that's basically it
i thought of all my ideas and there were
not 31 of them
so yeah i don't know i i guess i could
have forced it but you know with five or
six videos left to force i was just like
no this has always been something that
i've done for fun and you know i want it
to always be like that ultimately this
is entertainment and i don't think it's
that entertaining if i my whole heart
and soul isn't into it so you know i
just decided nah i'm not gonna not gonna
force it so even though i've got a few
videos left don't expect every day and
anyway this all brings us to the
elephant in the room which is shaving my
head we have to talk about that um i did
technically sort of promise to go bald
if i didn't upload every day this month
and i'm wondering what you guys thought
i meant when i said i would go bald i
mean are we talking spencer cornelia or
chrome dome rogan
what level are we talking about were we
talking like a one like a recruit in the
army you got barely any hair but you got
some are we talking about a recruit for
rogaine that's ultimately my question i
want to ask you guys um because bold is
not going to be a good look for for me
just cut it straight with you guys be
honest i've actually never been bald
before but i just know my general head
circumference and it's not going to be
pretty but i'm going to honor the
comment section you guys tell me below
what you thought i meant what you want
to see i will abide by it i'm just
begging you
have mercy or not maybe you want to see
the world burn in which case i respect
it now moving on we have one more
announcement which is the children what
about the children put the rules on
screen for a coffee zilla christmas real
quick we're already past the 25th which
means there are two possibilities we get
to a million before december 31st or we
don't now you guys know either way we're
giving away money for charity i think
we're probably not gonna hit our goal
but
since it's been such an incredible year
um either way we're gonna give away 10k
whether we hit it or not you know just
on behalf of the coffeezilla fans it's a
good cause save the children which
technically if you're thinking i scammed
you because none of it really mattered
and i was gonna give away 10k either way
that is technically what's going on here
um i'll be posting the receipt to my
twitter account or on the community tab
whenever we do it it's going to be
before the 31st but um i just honestly
want to take a second to thank you guys
from the bottom of my heart no this
wouldn't be possible without you guys
this has been an incredible year and to
all the shareholders i hope you take
credit for this okay it is because of
you that this month we were able to save
the children but also i hope you guys
don't mind if i just you know take a
step back and just chill for a bit so we
can always make this fun this year has
been a hell of a run i think we won like
third best youtuber by dextero just this
month we've had phileon tom nash spencer
cornelia patrick boyle playing bagel big
thanks to all of those guys as well but
to recap 10k to charity not daily tell
me how bald i need to go and that's it
with the announcements let's get on to
the video
ladies and gentlemen i am joined today
by spencer cornelia the fake guru hunter
my brother in arms and today we are
doing a tier list of the best or worst
fake gurus how you doing spencer you
excited i have never been more excited
in my life we're gonna take these guys
down hell yeah okay so i've combined a
list of the people you and i have
covered this year and we are going to
rate them of our opinion of how bad or
good they are s to f and to give you the
rules spencer's a bit backwards we're
going f is you're bad at being a fake
guru okay it's reversed as tier you are
you are reaching tai lopez dan lok
levels of enlightenment okay but at the
trash tier it's like hey give up give it
up go work at mcdonald's right you stop
stop wasting your time is it sad that we
could do this for like five days we've
got hundreds
we had to whittle this down as best we
could we had to whittle this down and i
already started with like a stripped
back the biggest people that i talked
about because i was like honestly dude
there's too many scams you and i were
talking we have never had more scams to
cover than we do right now and i think
we get into it who do you want to start
with let's start with phase k or x phase
k uh where are we putting him at right
he's gotta be trashed here he got kicked
out of his group oh that's a good point
when he's done he got he got killed well
no no
not
his profession his profession was over
phase
k sorry k tr i agree i agree didn't do
his job terminated job terminated job
terminated
up next i want to talk about what do you
think of aiden ross now this guy was
doing a gambling sponsorship he did
by the way full disclosure he is my
financial advisor so he i go to him for
crypto advice
token yeah that's how i get rich milf
token well you're not going to do well
right now unless you're pumped and
dumped i i think there's a c how about c
because yeah it probably helps some
people make a little a few dollars
here's the thing though here's the thing
he's still doing it like when when i did
the rhubarb stuff like a lot of people
quit they're like oh yeah this is messed
up aiden ross just switched over to a
new sponsorship i think he's with steak
now i'm gonna go ahead and say b i'm
gonna bump him up i mean he's not i
wouldn't call him a professional he kind
of sought moonlights you know he does
his regular streams and he does his
gambling streams but i'm going to go
ahead and say b the guy he just doesn't
care his audience hated it and he's like
all right well i'm going to just keep
doing it i guess fair i'm in the mood to
trash people we're going jay mazzini
next i agree let's do it jay mazzini he
is smashed here he was terminated
terminated from society get your ass i'm
actually getting k up i'm going k to f f
tier because i mean j mazzini is the
worst fake guru ever
he he's in prison right now for what he
did so i would say that you can't get
more trashed here than that he should
start um i mean he's honestly better off
working at wendy's i think he would do a
lot better there up next let's bring in
one of your guys the ace family you
covered these guys a lot obviously don't
they have a course or something i think
we're going c here austin came out with
a how to get rich on social media course
so he he touched on that fake guru life
he wanted he wanted it he went from like
oh i'm like this like guy started from
the bottom he quickly like got the lambo
got the house and
quickly does the hey do you want to be
rich like me buy my course now why are
you not going uh because again it's
reverse so i i guess he's in a lot of
trouble now so he's obviously not an s
tier but why are we putting him at sea
does is is his life always embroiled in
scams
i think there's a lot brewing underneath
the surface i think they've built up a
life of facade there's a lot of lawsuits
in the in the works but they haven't
gotten there yet they have not been
convicted hmm c for
c for convicted okay
um
up next let's we gotta we gotta go to
sam teal now this is the guy we both did
the guy in the middle the guy who will
yell at you
sam teal i remember him yeah the the
cocaine trader
he's here what he's doing he's he's
entertainment he's perfect entertainment
show a video of him harry please the
crazy thing is is by you just watching
this video right now you could have
fully automated your business that guy
is borderline the troll versus like he's
like trolling but he's also like it's he
he's actually selling stuff i don't know
i haven't figured it out and that's the
mystery it's that's what keeps me so
interested in this guy like what does he
do
does he spend time on a yacht does he
work at wendy's we don't know yeah but
it gets me coming back he he's brought
it to the point of parody but then a lot
of these guys are at that level so you
go well is this a joke or is it are you
serious i think i i can't tell i want to
cover some you have a lot of people on
this list by the way you've been busy
this year buddy by the way can we give
it up to spencer we're having such a
great year guys go subscribe to spencer
cornelia he's had a great year and i
want to make it even better for him but
give me one of these guys who are we
talking about here who's this
steve stevens it was brought to my
attention that spencer did a video
regarding my money management program
and took an example of a clip from money
talks six years ago so if you're going
to try to come up with your dumbass
theory make sure it's valid little
because you're sure as [ __ ] steve
stevens made a huge mistake because he
learned the hard way not to call me out
if you call me up publicly i'm coming
after you and i had a blast making that
video so that is that is a video that a
lot of friends share because of how
funny it is so we've got to go we got to
go b i'm giving him b because he's been
in the game for a long time he's been
able to keep up the facade for a while
and he does sports betting right
what he did he's a sports consultant and
so he teaches people how to make money
gambling on sports and i can tell you he
is not a sharp he does not win long term
if you're going to portray to act like
you have money you're going to have to
film a better show than sitting in your
second room in your apartment with a 10
print in your background the funny thing
is the way to make money sports betting
is sell sports betting it's the likes of
the fake guru like most things dude like
most things the way you get good at the
way you make tons of money on amazon is
not from jeff bezos it's from all the
people who want to work for jeff bezos
got the shovel we need a shovel
shovels baby i know but at respect for
him he's been he's been in the game for
a while he keeps the and he's got a tv
show honestly i'm creating a new tier
i'm going to call it the shovel tier
this guy is going in the shovel too
we're crazy
this is this is for all the people who
think i only go after people with clout
this guy does not have a big social
media presence but this guy has been
going for four years at raising money
for the mike g deal and i have heard
from his lawyers within the past two
weeks ooh yeah the mike g deal you've
been through it dude about this uh hey
legally this guy you're taking some for
the team to be honest right now honestly
i look at you and go hey better your
lawyers than mine okay um i think he's
in the trash tier i have to throw him in
the trash i'm i'm dunking him in the
trash can really yeah i think this guy's
been raising i did a i wish i had your
skill at looking at wallets this guy's
bitcoin while it had four million
dollars he's been raising money for a
deal so get this deal bro s tier bro
bro what are you talking about mike
she's got four bill
so get this he promised on a hundred
thousand dollar investment he promised a
56
billion with a b payout bro the guy is
as dear dude actually
i'm creating a new thing i'm creating a
new tier yeah bro uh
six 5.6 billion no 56 billion oh oh
56 billion s's
mike g tier that's that's mike
his lawyer so get this he sent me an
email and said if you take the video
down before the end of december we'll
close the deal but if you keep that
video up the deal is not going to close
this guy i'm telling you is a fiction
writer man this guy every single day
writes an email update to his list he
gives an update every single day on why
the deal hasn't closed it is remarkable
what deal what deal that's the thing
it's a crypto deal it's the
cryptocurrency oh i just i just like the
idea of just like always referring to
the deal the deal's not dead it's called
mike g deal no stephen you have to
understand this guy gets into the seoul
south korea bankers the central
government the solar these bankers are
coming over to close the deal
there's lawyers involved gee the deal
one of them got kovid so that pushed the
deal back a week
guys i would have gotten the deal done
but honestly look we ran out of
sparkling water at the office and i had
to go refill it i am telling you dude
getting on his email list is enjoyable
it's that awesome i'm signing up right
now single day there's a new update and
he is so creative
for four years for four years this is
not for a month this is for four years
the deal
is done
i i love that dude the deal is done
listen okay who are we doing next we got
hey tecly dude he's been out here
working hard man um he just wants to
launch a token giving a million dollars
of his own money where he doesn't give a
million dollars dude what's wrong with
that have you happened to see the coin
recently because the criticisms for us
because i actually did a video a little
bit for you on this the criticisms for
us were that all these people were
making money since then the the coin has
tanked hey dude don't hey you're that's
fun dude okay first of all you're right
fine right bud is not cool hoddle that
all the way down boys huddle it all the
way you know i feel bad i honestly feel
bad like the holders i have no problem i
love
the community i love you guys it's only
tech lead that i've ever had a problem
with you know what it and it wasn't just
safe that's good yeah it wasn't just the
tech like it wasn't just uh i would say
the million stuff it was also the trend
black stuff how he carried himself there
yeah there's a little of a little bit of
bad blood there but you know what i'm
starting the new year clean slate dude
all these guys i think i'm actually
giving hey look listen 2022 is the year
coffeezilla gives love not finds love i
already found love but we're going with
the far left one cody covers cody covers
he deserves an s tier with sam teal
these two are excellent at yelling in
the camera who's co put up cody covers
okay cody covers will return it's like
72 000 percent in a month it's going to
get you access to every bet that i
dropped for the rest of my life i repeat
access to every bet that i dropped for
the rest of my life more confident than
he's ever been i'm more confident than
i've ever been that this guy is dead i
agree
you know what um i'm gonna i'm gonna
agree with you but i'm going to i'm
actually bumping him down to a i'm not
going to lie i don't like it's not nice
has another is that another level dude
don't mess with sam dude but they both
figured out the formula which is yelling
at the screen and telling you you're
going to make millions oh
did they do all of that without having
to do any work on their own because it's
fully automated for you
right as they rake it in it's a good
good strategy actually i should uh i
should do it i think we go with the two
women now i know people accuse me of not
equal opportunity for women and i say
hey listen there's a lot of women
scammers out there too it's fine who are
we talking about now i think she's just
in the f
who is no no sorry she's shoveled here
no no she's shoveled here that's crypto
queen crypto queen chloe
how could i be so naive how could i
former playmaker it's all about crypto
queen dude spencer sometimes you find
people i go
where
where did you find these people i mean i
listen guys i am i have all access to
all these feeds too but sometimes
spencer digs one out and i'm just like
goes to the shovel for the shovel tear i
agree shout out to all the people
sending me stuff i do not
find these people it's all the people
that send them to me so thank you for
finding these people but yeah chloe is
shoveled here because she is selling you
the dream it's just one pump and dump
after another and it's actually going to
lead us to our next special contestant
jaylene ojeda so these these two are
kind of similar they're playing the
influencer game where they're going to
team up with someone and sell you on how
they're going to get you rich so she's a
day trader she all her pictures are
involving her assets but she's going to
teach you how to day trade now when you
say assets you mean
she's a very voluptuous woman okay okay
she gets a lot of attention day trading
okay okay
i think c
i think c a for assets
she gets an a in the appearance i'll
tell you she's a nice looking girl
she'll get your attention hey listen
you're not to get her number okay
spencer relax okay
actually i'm bringing her down to c for
that okay i don't want you i don't want
you to get any ideas um not my type not
my time i only like fake gurus that are
into real estate not the day trading
fake gurus well hey speaking of day
trading gurus into real estate dean
graziosi oh
listen how dare you call this guy a fake
guru you put him in the list i said hey
have some respect have some respect for
the guy who did it first
the truth of the matter is these are the
toughest times we've seen in history hi
i'm dean graziosi and using just one of
the simple techniques that you'll learn
in my course on how to profit in today's
changing market i want to jump on real
quick one last time and say
congratulations
for reserving your spot for registering
for the webcast training i'm going to be
doing i'm so excited listen in these
crazy changing sometimes uncertain times
what do you think about this guy he is a
master every single every six months
he's got a new scheme to get to sell you
dean grazie
real estate changes all the time it
doesn't stay the same and you know what
the strategies always have to be updated
spencer
he's an a i think he's he's a legend
yeah dude honestly eight-year but
wow the best part to me is how they
claim to be entrepreneurs it's like they
pitch this entrepreneur but all they are
is salesman they sell a new product
every six months never ending right the
product is entrepreneurship
i sell entrepreneurship oh you know what
you can even argue that he's in the
shovel tier because he sells the shovels
because he sells the master class he
teaches you how to teach i'm not putting
him in a list with a bunch of no-name
crypto queen chloe's okay dude half dean
grazie elsie has earned more than that i
want to take a second to honor the great
rice gum
um now as you guys know he was part of
the save the kids he's been part of a
few things but i think this is a classic
example of like you may actually be too
dumb to be involved in like it's kind of
this weird thing where you're so dumb i
don't know if you're making money but
you're definitely like it's arguable
whether you can even be held accountable
for your actions because it's like i
don't actually know if he's
i just think he knows the words clout
money
and
uh you know women i'm sensing a james
any collab down in the trash tier i
think trash care i think trashed here
for sure
dunk them all right uh who we got
probably made a big mistake too uh these
guys need to start learning you don't
call me out publicly and so he alleged
some things about my character to all of
his followers and it ignited within me
my favorite video to make which is to
call these guys out so i went into a
deep dive and why he's a fake sports
betting guru big time fake guru yeah the
sports betting types it's a very
interesting thing you basically go like
i'm the master of luck i'm the master
well it no and and you could say you
couch that within like strategy you go
like oh i have seen into the even though
people have like sophisticated
algorithms for this you with your little
intuition are gonna beat that yeah i
think he's i think he's shoveled here
too we gotta put him with steve stevens
these are the las vegas sports bettors
good good company with steve stevens now
we got mr versus who's this oh mozzie vs
mozzy vs decided to scare me a little
bit after my video on him he called me
and then texted me my home address yeah
my lawyers heard about that just to make
sure it was okay what's going on spencer
are you okay oh i'm good checking it
just checking in on you i want all the
smoke damn it feels good to be a
gangster i'm calling him out hey look
it's good i like it i like it he's down
in the shovel tier he's he's selling
he's selling the system he's selling the
dream this guy is as big of a fake guru
as there is can we get a clip of this
guy i've been professionally sport been
for like four years a pro sport's been
pretty much somebody who bets on sports
it's like this when you go to paris you
got to see eiffel tower when you go to
new york you want to see the statue of
liberty when you come in vegas you got
to see me as far as being king for our
next guest i want to talk about the paul
the po one paul actually i should have
put jake on here too but um you know
he's had a big win recently we'll give
him a day off but uh logan paul hey baby
i gotta give him some love i'm putting
him a nest here here's why okay he
always has a new scheme and i think the
idea of like i've changed i'm a new i'm
a different logan paul it's such a
brilliant like way to couch you know i'm
just moved on to my next little scheme
first it was dink doink it's krypto zoo
oh his pokemon he loved pokemon for a
little while and uh while he's making
money it's it's an interesting thing and
it was it was merch for a while it was
you know filming it japanese forests but
it's always like one thing to the next
and it's it's a bit of a grift like that
is what master grifters do is they never
stay still they always move on this is
much like brian rose who i don't know
why brian rose is not on this list i
would put him at s here as well this is
an exciting time but you have to pull
the trigger you have to make the
decision today to start doing something
about it so i look forward to being with
you inside the defy accelerator uh no
dude he's trashed here brian rose is
done he's done he's out for the count
logan paul knocked him out in his next
boxing match good point good fight yeah
actually ryan rose's trash here you're
right i have it reversed in my head um
well now that cove is over what does he
have to talk about no he's talking about
defy he's a deep man i don't keep up
with him anymore no no one does but um
but he's selling device that's what i'm
saying though grifters they never they
never like the hallmark of a grifter is
you never stay still you revisit them a
year later and they're on to something
new it's like it's like it's not you
don't stay with oh dink doing because
dink doing always crashes and then you
have to get on to your next wave right
oh cryptozoo oh we're about to launch
we're about
hey yeah that's how it works i like his
podcast you're gonna hate me i like his
podcast
well his content used to be good hey
that's that's the brilliant side of it
is if you have something going on you
can get away with this stuff because
people like you for the good stuff you
do and uh
that's fine agreed controversy sells the
paul brothers have figured it out they
only seem to be getting bigger
yeah i know it is like they are they're
a little bit undefeated it's scary so
who are you going to box out of this
list that's that's we got to drum up
some coffeezilla fighting i can't take
it off spencer it'd be a danger for me
to box these people and a danger to
their health is what i mean because well
i don't know if you know this but i
learned the ancient art of the
dim mac death touch earlier this year oh
i have become a threat to
others and myself honestly i uh i was in
the shower the other day and i
accidentally trigger pointed myself just
i couldn't move for a week okay so i'm
just gonna be honest with you these
people would be in serious bodily danger
if we were to step in the ring i'm sorry
logan i won't do that to you no matter
how much i think you're scamming people
joe jardinsa
joe jardinsa we have next this guy joe
jardinson is another very under the
radar billionaire we've probably never
heard of him no nor has anyone else he
runs 47 companies that no one's ever
heard of and he promotes scam coins
he's trashed here we're dunking him in
the trash here i was gonna go be for
billionaire but trashed here no dunk him
give it to him spencer give it to him
hey this guy's this guy popped up
recently and he's uh no he's done but
anyway scott yancey's the next one this
guy did the real estate seminars okay i
am very much against the real estate
seminars and he and scott yancey so
self-aware that he came out with a video
titled don't fall for the scams and then
explain the scam i've i've seen this guy
i've seen this guy yeah he's like as a
tv show or something he did yeah he did
for a while
oh that's where a lot of these guys come
from shovel tier yeah
selling
uh next our last person our honestly
anti-climactic and another real estate
guru yeah she sold me real estate the
reason why i got interested is because i
just saw her big bodacious booty right
on camera and it just enticed me to
listen to what she had to say and she
was teaching real estate millions what's
her name
zamina orr samina or
um i'm gonna put her in the air i'm
assuming you've never signed up for her
only fans that's probably why you don't
know her correct yeah yeah some people
do is that where you learn real estate
now is only fans
that's where i learned how real estate
skills actually is uh you can learn
marketing apparently but no she's she's
buying a lot of real estate now um
simply from her expertise i googled her
right before this just to grab an image
for the uh for the thing be careful if
the wife walks in she might not like
what she has to see that was weird it
was an uncomfortable moment because i
was just like typing in i go whoa
okay this is the most safer work photo i
could find i didn't know that i didn't
know only fans in real estate really
collect like collided like that but
she's doing what a lot of these people
are doing which is they team up with
someone who might be semi-legit who can
sell the information and then they're
just using it for marketing purposes
that's it it's the tai lopez model it's
i'm an expert in everything and then you
sell the course with your expert buddy
right right right yeah i i don't know if
you saw tai lopez just launched a crypto
coin uh i haven't watched your video yet
yeah radio shack is now launching a coin
the business that failed to adapt to the
internet
is going to be the first to lead the d5
revolution baby sign me up well what a
journey this has been are are we
actually serious that mike g is going at
the top here i do like it in a weird way
the the deal is never done
just like us the hey listen the scams
have never all been caught there's
always more scams to be done here and uh
i think that's our lesson today is top
of the list mike g then we got
our boys
logan paul and
what's his name sam teo1234 and
samteal1234
yeah i think honestly this has been a
lot of real estate crap it's been the
year of real estate and crypto i feel
like you've done a really good job with
the crypto everyone's hot on crypto man
those returns are so juicy aren't they
hey they're juicy baby i used to cover
crypto scan or i used to cover like um i
guess i still do but um in the past when
i've covered scams and it's like 50 of
your 100 a year i've like been like oh
that's horrible you would promise that
in crypto people don't get out of bed
for less than twelve thousand percent
it's like it doesn't even make sense but
ladies and gentlemen that's about it for
today i hope you enjoyed fake guru
tearless with spencer cornelia go
subscribe to this channel go subscribe
and pump the stock for me so we can save
the kids this month and we can dunk on
these fake gurus we got to throw them
all in the trash can that's right and we
are not coming back tomorrow because i'm
taking a break but i'll see you very
soon see ya